yes hello dr. Joe Wallach yes sir how
can we help you
yeah I've been having these like you
know I've been doing write regular
duties and they do the laundry or
something everything's fine early in the
morning and then my I'm just walking
around nothing heavy I left and also get
back when crap what's really bad and had
to lay on the couch until it kind of go
laid in one bath so kind of paint this
and the cramping little bit
I couldn't move okay now it up okay
you're you're buzzing you're breaking up
a little bit here when you're say in
fact you come out your lumbar area your
lower back you're on right down the left
okay okay and how much he away Patrick
I'm probably I probably what 198 I'm
sorry I have any other issues did you
know of any other L 1 2 & 3 the bulging
disc that they're getting better I'm
using some of your products maybe isn't
no game good and do you have anything
like diabetes or high blood pressure
no any okay a history of asthma all
problems constipation diarrhea no I do
have a ball stated here swimming for
cancer but then I know it came back on
my face they're gonna get picked was it
I was taking like a three nine of them a
day and then I took a month but it
didn't pay me back okay now his stuff on
your face is it eczema dermatitis or
rosacea or is it again we'd say
non-malignant you know economy vandal
cell basal cell cancer yeah I think ones
not malignant I think you don't know
yeah yeah basal cells just invade
locally they don't tend to go anyplace
else but they can be disfiguring so you
do have to deal with them alright
Charmaine you there I'm here
okay here's Patrick 198 pounds and he
has a chronic issue with back problems
discs and all that kind of stuff would
you do for him and just a quick review
Patrick is 198 pounds he's plagued with
back issues and degenerative disc
problems and so forth what would you do
for him diet why is the settlement
program to support healthy maintenance
and repair
well first I get him on a gluten-free
diet and obviously no no fried foods no
oils and then for although issues he has
I personally would get him unto healthy
brain and heart pecs and I would add the
gluco gel to that and the MSM okay you
get an a-plus here yep
I have him if he wants to liquid glucose
gel he can take three quarts a month in
an ounce with each meal if he wants to
take the capsules he can take good two
large bottles of the capsules the gluco
gel take 15 a day five five and five
five with each meal and of course in MSM
from our free live division is a
beautiful product let me tell you we
just use that racehorses when I was
practicing veterinarian it's just great
for discs between the vertebrae we're
talking about cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue of all kind so
fibromyalgia lupus sarcoidosis arthritis
only kind of stuff and I go ahead with C
as you point out the MSM I'd have him
take three of those he could hit three
three times a day if he wanted to the
MSM are three twice a day whatever the
budget allows and they're all designed
again to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone matrix and bone itself